hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
what you're looking at is one of the
most highly anticipated devices of 2014
this SmartWatch is the Moto 360 now
there are a lot of varying opinions on
smartwatches in general as a category
but this 360 is one of the most
important ones and it starts right off
with the name Moto 360 it's a circular
shell 360 degrees all around
well not quite 360 there's actually a
small bezel at the bottom that just cuts
off a bit of the display but other than
that it's essentially a circle now some
people hate this little bar at the
bottom they say it's distracting and
it's a design flaw and even a
deal-breaker but I found that a lot of
people saying this haven't actually used
the watch pass just looking at it for a
little bit and I found that your eye
really starts ignoring it when you get
to use a watch for a bit and I really
hardly notice anymore even though
obviously it's still there
so for the record this little bar is
kind of necessary for Motorola to
achieve this design behind it are the
display drivers and digitizer and the
ambient light sensor which have to go
somewhere and in all other smartwatches
we've seen it's in the form of a thicker
bezel and personally I'll take this thin
profile with the bottom bar any day so
the result of this design decision is a
beautiful watch it's made of metal all
around its ip67 certified it's really
well constructed so dust and water
resistant so no worries in the rain and
the thing is not nearly as heavy as it
looks I know it's made of metal but all
the electronics inside are pretty light
and it's a leather band the metal ones
are coming later for about $80 extra so
this one overall is pretty light at 49
grams so it's actually very manageable
now the thing is the size on your wrist
thing is very polarizing so I found for
a lot of people you know I gave it to my
mom who has pretty similar sized wrists
to me thin I guess and her immediate
reaction was okay this is way too big to
wear watch I'm not going to wear this
but you give it to someone like my buddy
Lou from unbox therapy who wears a
relatively massive g-shock watch all the
time on a much larger wrist switching to
a moto 360 makes it look tiny so dainty
and unacceptably small so it's something
you got to get used to for sure it's a
1.5 6-inch display I know I'm not coming
from wearing any watch previously so it
feels
pretty comfortable on my wrist I got
used to it pretty fast but there are no
to size options like the Apple watch so
you'll have to make this one work also
this is the black version there's also a
silver version as well and yes if you
wear it out enough you will get asked if
it's an Apple watch actually you can put
an Apple watch homescreen on the 360 and
it has a functioning clock and
everything which is pretty funny I'll
leave a link to that below so the only
underwhelming part of the watch's
Hardware is the display it's ok it's 1.5
6 inches diagonally as a circle and has
this beveled edge around the
circumference of the Gorilla Glass and
it looks interesting I guess but it
might have looked even cooler with this
seamless edge and the resolution is 320
by 2 90 so not a very high pixel density
at all you can easily see the pixels if
you look for them I guess but the good
thing is that it's an IPS display which
means it's pretty visible outdoors it's
much brighter than if they'd use an OLED
display so in pretty much all but direct
sunlight you can see this thing clearly
much more so than if they'd use OLED so
I'm happy with their choice so the
software on the Moto 360 is the same as
other smartwatches like we've seen in
the LG G watch and Samsung gear live
it's Android wear 1.0 and I'm actually
I've covered Android wear much more in
depth in a separate video I'll leave
that link right below that like button
so you can check it out it's essentially
your Android phones notifications and
Google now cards on your wrist now this
is a bit different because it's a
circular display of course so you have
Motorola circular watch faces and a lot
of round elements in Android wear that
really just look better on a circular
display the thing is there are also
parts of Android wear that look better
on a square display
so sometimes notifications text will get
cut off a little bit in the corners when
you're trying to scroll up and read them
I mean usually it does a pretty good job
of not cutting off any of the graphics
but it's not flawless and I feel like
maybe we could see a split down the road
of Android wear for round displays and
Android wear for square displays as much
as that would suck now the number one
thing people have asked the most about
with the Moto 360 is the battery life so
here's a scoop on the battery of the
Moto 360 the TLDR is it's ok it's not
bad but it's definitely not great so
it's a 300 or 320 million power battery
depending on who you want to believe and
it's a pretty large screen one point
five six inches compared to the battery
size and for that reason every single
minute of screen on time you have what
these watches counts a lot now a lot of
people have been reviewing this watch
have been using it a lot oh I got to
test it a lot I got to make sure I get
the battery life checked out and when
you use it a lot in fact more than
average you're going to take a massive
hit to the battery now I think I get
more notifications than the average
person I get plenty of Twitter
notifications Google+ notifications
Gmail stuff I have pretty much
everything turned on so I get calendar
stuff tasks all these reminders all day
so it's going off and it's working the
way I guess a normal SmartWatch should
and I tend to end the day with around 30
percent to 20 percent battery remaining
on a heavier day when I'm turning the
screen on more when I'm using Google
Maps Navigation directions on here when
I'm checking my heart rate when I'm
checking my steps when I'm using all
these ok Google commands and turning the
screen on over and over again is
listening to my voice a lot and the
screen is on a lot and those days I'll
end with maybe 10 percent battery left
or less but my day goes from 7 or 8 a.m.
to 2 a.m. the next morning so if you can
bear with it lasting 17 18 19 hours
before you have to charge it again
overnight then that's fine you'll charge
it every night now a big factor in this
is whether or not you have ambient mode
on the difference between ambient mode
on and off is when ambient mode is off
you check the screen it'll show you the
time and after a few seconds it'll
disappear and the screen turns back off
again and it's pretty sensitive in terms
of knowing when you bring it up to your
face obviously you can't really sort of
glance check it because it doesn't
really know when you're bringing it up
to your face or not but when you very
deliberately look at the watch it
clearly turns the face on and you can
check the time and your notifications
before it turns off a few seconds later
if you turn ambient mode off and it
warns you when you do this that this
will take a massive hit on battery life
but when you turn this off it'll leave
the screen on but dimly on forever
indefinitely so that's a lot more screen
on time and if you leave ambient mode on
you will not get nearly as much battery
life as you would if it was off default
out of the box ambient mode is off
and I think that's recommended I
wouldn't really suggest leaving the
clockface on especially because it's so
dim you won't really be able to see it
anyway so you might as well have the
face off and save battery I say leave
ambient mode off you'll get a full day
but if you turn ambient mode on you will
not get a full day the one really nice
thing about the battery though is
because it's so small it charges really
fast so if you get home at the end of a
workday you're going to go out that
night and you throw it on the charger
for half an hour you can get a lot back
into the battery and easily have enough
to go for the rest of the night and the
next thing is the charging mechanism is
pretty awesome
it is officially qi wireless charging so
you can use any old wireless charger you
have maybe your nexus one lying around
which is great but the dock it comes
with and the retail packaging is sweet
you put it on the dock it glows very
dimly with the time and your battery
percentage remaining which makes for a
nice alarm clock and it looks cool as
hell on a desk I'm a fan of the charging
so I did mention the ambient light
sensor is in that bottom bar that's one
of several ways to use the watch when
ambient mode is turned off you can
number one press the power button on the
side to wake the display number two you
can tap the display anywhere to wake it
up
I found myself actually doing that way
the most often and then number three you
can raise the watch up to your face and
the gyroscope will detect that you've
raised it and it'll light up the display
and then you have the ambient light
sensor which is what you can use to just
cover the face of the watch for a second
and that will dim the display for you
when you're done looking at it so here's
something weird about the SmartWatch
performance is very hit-or-miss
sometimes and this key word is sometimes
it's flawless you know super smooth
never hiccups and is totally fine but
other times and it's like 50/50 all the
times it's really stuttery and drops
frames and lags and is janky and yes it
is new software Android wear 1.0 and
it's not even a high end chip it's a TI
OMAP 3 but it really makes me wonder
what would have happened if they went
with a higher resolution display most of
the performance problems I'm seeing with
the Moto 360 happen right when I turn
the screen on for the first time makes
me think that there's some throttling
going on when the screen is off to save
some battery so that as soon as the
screen turns on and if I try
doing action too quickly the processor
hasn't throttled back up yet and it's
still kind of in this dormant mode and
that's why I'm seeing lots of choppiness
and lots and lots of dropped frames the
animations are all there it just takes a
second before they kick in and smooth
themselves out which seems like a
problem with the hardware more than the
software but again this is also first
generation Android where software so
it's probably a little bit of both so
the summary of it right now for the Moto
360 is really the summary for
smartwatches general smartwatches as a
whole are not ready for primetime
they're not like a full complete
compelling package for the majority of
people yet that being said this is the
best one you can get the Moto 360 is the
best SmartWatch you can get in my
opinion I've used a bunch of them I'll
continue to use more of them and test
more of them I want to check out the LG
G watch our I want to check out the
Apple watch so there are some other
things I want to test but this is the
best one I've used by a little bit if
you're willing to go form over function
meaning you like the way it looks enough
to deal with the fact that there are
some performance issues and you have to
charge it every night and it only works
with Android phones if you like the way
it looks enough to deal with all that
then this is great this is an awesome
SmartWatch and I wouldn't blame you for
buying it it's $250 it's not cheap but
it's also not the most expensive
SmartWatch out there either I will
continue to wear mine because I want to
see where Android wear moves in these
next few weeks and months there are some
updates coming out and I know that the
Moto 360 will basically be first in line
for those and assuming that these
software updates are good and they
optimize battery life and they take care
of some performance issues and they work
on other differences between the
circular and square interfaces then this
will probably end up being a pretty
sweet package and I'm glad I got it and
I'm glad I have it now so that I get to
observe these changes so thank you for
watching this has been the Moto 360
review if you want to leave a thumbs up
below if you enjoyed that would be great
and I'll talk to you guys in the very
next one peace
you